[Music]
one of the most important attributes of
origami is once we have studied and
understood the way paper folds and
unfolds we can apply those patterns to
things that are very different from
paper I hope by bringing the tools of
mathematics into my origami design that
I can then fold something that's
beautiful and that's unexpected my name
is Robert Lang and I'm a physicist and
an origami artist
origami is the Japanese name for the art
of folded paper and most origami is
folded from a single sheet of paper with
no cuts or tears
I have loved origami entire life I
pursued it ever since I was a kid but my
study was science and engineering I
worked for NASA doing research on lasers
but throughout that whole time I had
been pursuing origami developing designs
writing books so in 2001 I quit my job
to try to make a career out of origami
I've worked on a couple of different
folding patterns that were round and
would wrap into a cylindrical geometry
to fit into a rocket and I developed an
airbag in a car that inflates from a
small folded bundle so whenever an
engineer creates something that opens
and closes in a controlled way they can
make use of the folding patterns of
origami over the years math has allowed
me to realize as an artist shapes and
creations that I couldn't achieve any
other way
traditional origami was relatively
simple
the designs would have taken maybe 20 or
30 steps at most but today origami
pieces can be so complicated that they
can have tens hundreds maybe even a
thousand steps when I'm folding it's
like working with an old friend it's
like dancing with a partner whose moves
I know if I move this way I know my
partner is going to move that way and so
I explore the math develop the equations
solve the equations create the folding
pattern and then I find out what it
looks like and as often as not it is
beautiful
for me the driving force is that there's
always something new to try a new
problem a new subject a new shape that I
didn't think I was able to create before
but now I think I know how to realize it
and each time I solve a problem you get
this wonderful feeling and you want more
of those feelings when you're watching a
television show or a movie and you see
an actor holding a magazine or book or a
letter a lot of what you're seeing on
the screen was custom made by people
like me let me see their paper
if I've done my job right in creating
that piece of paper the possibilities
are literally endless I mean one single
piece of paper can communicate a huge
amount in telling the audience about the
character or about the scene
[Applause]
it's figuring out how this thing can
best do its job of being a part of the
story
[Music]
my name is Ross Macdonald and I create
paper props for movies and television
when I was a kid I was obsessed with
comics was obsessed with paper and
illustration and really loved that world
that I was reading or seeing on paper
I've done a little bit of everything for
years I worked as a magazine and
newspaper illustrator book illustrator
that eventually led me into making props
[Music]
for the last 25 years I've made tens of
thousands of paper props for close to 50
television shows and movies my first
major motion picture was babies day out
and I was hired basically as an
illustrator to illustrate a Pho 1930s
children's book I've done literally tens
of thousands of props for all five
seasons Boardwalk Empire I did the
Pawnee charter for an episode of Parks
and Recreation for joy I did all of the
patents for the mops that we see played
I did secrets socialite he's played for
The Wizard of lies
I've designed everything from passports
and maps and travel documents wanted
posters government forms FBI reports
psychiatric files agent identification
folders anything gets made of paper I
made at one time or another part of what
you need to figure out when you're
making a paper prop is the backstory of
the piece of paper you don't just take a
new book and slosh brown ink on to make
it look old you got to figure out how it
got worn how it got dirty the scene
might involve an actor reading three
lines out of a letter but you have to
figure out how old is it what kind of
paper isn't made out of how was the
paper made should it be made with carbon
paper should it be on onion skin is some
guy gonna pull out a ruffled piece of
paper from his pocket or is he gonna
pull it out of a file folder what color
paper should it be should it be yellow
should it be white should it be ivory
colored who's signing it what does their
handwriting look like what kind of ink
are they using when they write it what
kind of pen are they using and then
because no letter is ever three lines
you have to write the rest of the copy
in the letter depending on what I'm
making a project can take you know a day
an hour weeks months every page is
filled out every book has text on it
pictures every paper in the file folder
is is a real document that's all filled
out and created for example for The Book
of Secrets
they said just come up with secrets so I
said okay well let's do Roswell let's do
the Kennedy assassination let's do all
these crazy conspiracy theory things
then there was the research into those
specific things so you have to find all
that figure out how to recreate it
convincingly was a huge undertaking it
took about four months to really build
that prop and it's just communicated in
a split second in the scene have you
seen an evening paper I have here pieces
of paper
there's so many amazing things that
start off with a piece of paper and the
props that I'm making they're all part
of that sometimes when they go to the
theater I'm so excited I'm almost
shaking and it's not because I want to
see the driver's license I made from one
of the actors it's because I I did a
tiny bit of work on that movie and it's
that's very exciting to me in the end
you've produced this thing which you
know you've done your best job of
nailing getting absolutely right and you
know sometimes I'm just like wow you see
something like that in the final product
and realize that this thing you've
worked on is this huge moment in the
story that can be just really really a
great family
the paper airplane you folded in middle
school horrible design but I've thrown a
paper airplane 214 feet I'm John Collins
I am the paper airplane guy world record
holder for a paper aircraft distance for
the year we got the record was 2012 it
was you know one of the great days in my
life actually you know I look back at my
child being born in the world record
those are great moments for me
I named the world record plane after my
wife the name of the design is Suzanne
this is how you fold Suzanne you start
with the short side of the paper out on
the page and put it against the right or
not when you want to move out you've got
an accent after that is to take all
right straight down to the top of the
plane you fold the plane in half it's
just eight simple folds there are a lot
of different kinds of folding techniques
and a lot of different kinds of paper
airplane there's planes that boomerang
back there are planes that are made to
fly straight very far there are planes
that are made to stay in the air for a
long time every great paper airplane
distance or time aloft has very accurate
folding most people want to know how I
got into paper airplanes and the reality
as I never got out of them I am curious
by nature I love math and science the
cool thing about paper airplanes is it's
a way to actually discover something
real about flight what most people don't
know is that we don't know the exact
cause and effect for lift every little
paper airplane throw is like a little
science experiment here's the laboratory
right here in your hand that you could
use to do real science teachers kind of
don't like kids to do paper airplanes it
has this bad-boy kind of renegade
reputation if they could discover that
paper airplanes actually are science
that they're doing science and having
fun to it I think that's an incredible
breakthrough paper airplane throwing
class yes
[Music]
box Wars really feels like a medieval
battle the only difference is this with
cardboard
[Music]
there's rules to box wars but they're
very limited there's no winners we like
to say that if you're in a box Wars but
you've already lost I'm Ross I'm one of
the supreme overlords of box Wars box
Wars is a collective of people that love
to get together create cardboard
creations and then destroy them in an
epic battle it's more about
competitiveness in being creative the
only materials that you can use
cardboard adhesives like tape hot glue
whatever you can find in packaging
that's the stuff that we like to use to
build our suits every single battle has
a new engineering challenge like
building a giant aircraft carrier or
building a monster truck that actually
rolls or a train which has to carry in a
whole bunch of policemen we encourage
people to come down to our events and
build as elaborate costumes as they can
possibly make
once they've build the props then we all
gather at a park and then we battle
everyone comes in and clashes and
destroys everything stuff that we've
spent weeks on designing it's all gone
in seconds it just started off really
small but then all the sudden it blew up
there's generally around about 50 to 100
people in the actual battle and then it
can be hundreds and hundreds of
spectators we've got chapters that have
started up all around the world we've
had groups in Japan in Europe and
America in Canada
it seems so childish but it's fantastic
that a concept like this crosses
cultural and language barriers
Vauxhall's is based around comedy that's
the whole point of box wars we're losers
what we're doing is quite pathetic we
should all have real jobs but here we
are building stuff out of cardboard if
you laugh at us that's exactly what we
want
[Music]